Hey YouTubers it's Charlie! so this week for my
Game of Thrones bonus video I wanted to talk
all about Lyanna Stark a really big character
in the context of a song of ice and fire but
someone we might not ever actually get to
meet the comments by Littlefinger and Sir
Barristan Selmy in episode four set the Internet
on fire with R plus L equals J confirmations
technically they did not confirm anything
about Lyanna Stark maybe maybe not son so what l'm gonna
do is a history for her character and then
explain the context for the prophecy that
everyone's talking about the one that Rhaegar
was obsessed with the prince who was promised
to just careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far most of this
history is taken from anecdotal comments based
on things the characters have said in story
that we've already covered the part of Lyanna
Stark will be played by Lily Collins in
snow white attire people always asked me whenever
I use other pictures for characters that we
haven't seen on the show Lyanna start was
the sister of Brandon Stark and Ned Stark
Brandon Stark was the oldest brother Ned Stark
was the middle Lyanna Stark was the youngest
she was like the Arya of their family during
season one of the show Arya was even told
that she looked like her aunt Lyanna she shares
a lot of personality traits with her but
they're not like carbon copies of each other
Arya Stark isn't like the reincarnation
of Lyanna George RR Martin is just famous
for repeating metaphors over time so a lot
of event situations characters in present
day resemble things that happened in the past
that is talked about but that doesn't mean
that they'll play out the exact same way he
just a self-described history nut and a lot of
times in real world history it seems like
events are repeating themselves as described
by Ned Lyanna was wolf blooded very tomboyish
very hot-blooded she said to really have enjoyed
using swords although there father wouldn't
allow her to walk around carrying a sword
that she was very skilled on a horse so well
accounts she was capable of taking care of
herself very strong-willed independent and
capable of defending herself she was no flowery
maiden speaking of which I know Littlefinger
made this comment about the crown of roses
at the tourney of Harrenhal last week it just
that Lyanna is described as being very fond
of the blue roses that grew at Winterfell
brand Stark on the show right now actually
does get a picture like an actual look at
Lyanna start he sees a girl that looks like
Arya we did a Maggie the frog flashback so
it's possible that we could get a Lyanna Stark
flashback there's no guarantee and brand Stark
is even part of season five so until they say otherwise
you know most of what we learn about her is gonna
to be when characters talk to other characters
about her in historical context actually that's
a really good way to do it is just a little
more creative way to convey history to do
exposition so moving along into the really
important moments that referred about on the
shelf that the tourney of Harrenhal right
before that was when she had been promised
to Robert Baratheon when that happened she is
said to have told Ned that she had some misgivings
about Robert ya know just because he was such
a manwhore that's important for context in
that Lyanna Stark was not in love with Robert
Baratheon as is true of most political marriages
so then we moved to the tourney of Harrenhal
the show might not ever explain it or they
they might tell it in an offhanded story but
in addition to the Rhaegar crown of blue roses
moment that Littlefinger talked about there
was another big thing that happened at the
tournament she was a good friend of Howland
Reed one of the crannogmen ya know Jojen Reed
this character here his father he was very
young he is being bullied by three other squires
from three larger houses later in the tournament
a night wearing the sigil of a laughing tree
unhorsed all three of the squires that had
been bullying Howland Reed the identity of
the knight was a huge mystery there's a lot of
theories that knight was Howland Reed
himself getting revenge on the squires that
were making fun of him but there's also a theory that
mystery knight was Lyanna Stark after he won
the last bout the knight ran off into the woods
took off his armor and and then ran off Rhaegar
Targaryen was ordered to go find out who the
knight was but he only found the shield with
the laughing tree on it also during that tournament
Rhaegar is said to have played such a beautiful
song that it made Lyanna Stark weep so everybody
loses their shit when Rhaegar gives the prize
to Lyanna Stark a short time after the tournament
is when he is said to have kidnapped her and
run off is a lot of anecdotal evidence to
those two characters having something of a
connection with each other whether it's love
or mutual interests or something else remains
to be seen so here is where we get to the
prophecy that Rhaegar is said to be obsessed
with the prince who was promised the best
theory is is that it wasn't so much that he
was in love with Lyanna Stark he might've
just thought that she was the crucial part
of the fulfillment of the prophecy we actually
saw a version of this prophecy but it was
only in the books we didn't see it on the
show Daenerys has a bunch of visions in the
house of the undying they just they cut that
way down to the show this is where it gets
a little confusing because there's a lot of
conflicting stories about who might be the
prince who was promised you know a lot people also
think that Daenerys might be so be your princess
who was promised in that case in Daenerys's
vision in the house the undying she sees Rhaegar
saying this is the prince who is promised
and it's seemingly Aegon the baby that was
supposed to have gotten its head dashed against
the wall by the mountain the problem with
visions is that they're open to interpretation
and sometimes visions that you get can be
of alternate timelines like you had things
gone differently these things might have gone
this way so don't ever take visions in the
literal context side note there's also a lot
of theories that the prince who is promised
is also the is or a high character as told
by Melisandre just two different ways of interpreting
a very old prophecy into Melisandre comes
from the faith of the Red God they're going
to have a different interpretation about the
fulfillment of the prophecy then say someone
from westeros is part of the faith of the
seven when Rhaegar took Lyanna though he took
her to the tower of joy that just like on
the northern edge of dorm and a lot of people
were hoping we would see it when Jamie and
Bron went to Dorne there's no promise  of that
but ya know we might get an easter egg like someone
might casually mention something about that
we don't know the whole reason why Rhaegar
took Lyanna Stark ViserysTargaryen actually
told Daenerys that Rhaegar was unhappy in
his marriage to Elia of Dorne so it's possible
that he was just infatuated with Lyanna that
he is someone who spent his entire life dedicated
to the prophecy as a child he actually decided
to become a warrior after reading the prophecy
so I do think that he felt like Lyanna Stark
was part of the prophecy when she was first
taken Brandon Stark found out about it and went
to the red keep to get help from Aerys Targaryen
to to ask him to deal with it Aerys had Brandon
and his companions other you know highborn
nobles arrested for treason he accused them
of plotting murder they chose trial by combat
in Aerys shows fire as his champion this is
where things really heat up with Robert's
rebellion this is the primary reason it started
not because Lyanna Stark was taken starting
rebellion requires massive support one way
to do that is to kill the warden of the North
his oldest son and several highborn nobles
so John Arryn joined forces with the North
just like Littlefinger said he would do with Roose Bolton now and they declared war on the Targaryens
so the rebellion didn't happen overnight during
that Rhaegar had to leave for battle at the
Trident that's where Robert killed him he
is said to have died whispering Lyanna's name
and when Ned finally found Lyanna at the tower
of joy she was said to be covered in blood
and whispered to Ned promise me the theory is
is that Ned found her after just having a
baby and she said promise me you'll take care
of him and that's what she meant one of the
few people that still live in the context
of the show that was at the tower of joy is
Howland Reed we haven't seen him but ya know
unless confirmed otherwise he still presumed
to be alive running around somewhere so if
you're ever looking for like absolute confirmation
on who Lyanna Stark's child was or whether
or not she actually had a child there still
someone the show can trot out to do that and
are expected to go down that way you if we
ever learn who Jon Snow's mother is it'll probably
be in somewhat more vague terms is more of
what we saw last week you know characters
telling stories that seem to imply a certain
outcome I just think it's a lot more fun that way
most of the best theories I've seen about
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark at the
tower of joy take a more practical approach to
the characters he took her more because the
prophecy then then because of love it wasn't
so much an act of aggression as an act of
utility this must happen this must come to
pass so that we can fulfill the prophecy so if
the show does anything it is just gonna be
dropping hints what I'm really hoping they
do is that we see John snow and more white
walker scenes so we can see whether or not
the show is going to back him into season
six and seven anybody's fair game to be killed
off but it's easy to see when the show is
backing a certain character is one of the
pillars of the story like we want you to feel
a certain way about this character like Stannis
for instance he seemed like an asshole for
the first couple seasons but now the show
wants you to think of him as a good character
so the rest of the episodes this season will
give you an idea of how the show wants you
to think of John snow lately it is been that
he has very special power that Melisandre
want sent to explore all the stars are confirmed
Ward so she could just be talking about that
and even if he really is Ned's Bastard and
not Lyanna son he was still be half noble
I mean he would still have the same kind of power
in his blood the Gendry had so there is number of interpretations
but you guys can let me know ya know do you think
that John snow is the son of Lyanna Stark
and Rhaegar Targaryen and do you think that
the show is going to back him is like one
of the most important characters you know along with
Daenerys into like season six and seven in related
news episode five tonight be sure to subscribe
to get that I'm gonna be doing a new round
of the giveaway I will be giving away the
signed copies of feast for crows and dance with
dragons they're both hardbacks signed by George
R R Martin so just watch my episode five video
you guys will see in case you guys haven't
seen it you can click here for my episode
five video I'll add the annotation after I
post the video tonight and you can click here
to learn all about the history of Winterfell
thank you so much for watching, everybody high
five and I'll see you guys tonight!